oh [ __ ] [ __ ] oh god oh [ __ ] what up it's
your boy skinny penis hello everybody my
name is markiplier and welcome back to
an old classic turbo dismount I don't
know what compelled me to play this game
today I saw it in my list way way way
down and I was like man I haven't played
this in in ages so I was like yeah oh
[ __ ] it all I'll play that wait rampage
insane let's try that one oh yeah I
remember you
Oh IRA wait where's my freaking face
there I am alright what am I supposed to
do I don't even remember what obstacles
there loot box
well [ __ ] yeah give me some loot box I
don't even know what that does I'm gonna
buy a bunch oh my god what is that what
is oh oh no that's oh that that's a
jawbone that that's not right pose okay
all right why is my bauble what's my
bobblehead all funky hey how's it going
a friend all right no no all right let's
go with that one go yeah I guess oh I
can see where am I going
wait don't come back please I know we're
getting out of play I wasn't steering
correctly and then the camera just went
away oh there I am I was fine yeah I'm
fine everyone else is just a [ __ ]
idiot whatever let's try this again here
we go I gotta use the arrow keys to
steer that didn't work at all we okay
the [ __ ] the point oh just a lot of
death explosions that was it pretty much
for the most part that's right different
level you're hanging on I don't want one
that I have to steer I want to do
minimal work possible impossible great
oh this is a classic
oh it's beautiful Oh perfect go baby go
watch
I remember I remember the appeal this
mrs. bumble bee all right where's mr.
bumble bee all right little eager but
that's all right
I remember the appeal of this game I
remember zooming on that ass off you're
welcome
let's go straight down the middle here
Shoop Oh half speed well okay we're
already drifting I think we're gonna
make it
this is bumble bee mr. reach oh that's
not right hey I'm tall hey guys I'm tall
ooh that's all right why present the ass
to thine own destruction I understand I
understand the desire and I understand
the appeal my head just is so easily
detached and I feel like that's wrong I
want see what mr. oof
move that's scary that's a good one wait
no this one's strategic I like it it's
very strategic I'm like a [ __ ] spider
for full speed baby and go to give me
[ __ ] wait hey not really the leg that's
a problem turbo pad plus a ramp to get
us over this let's do it go whoa oh [ __ ]
sick flip dude hey I get points for foot
oh wow all right well old creaky ah oh
look it's it's true - its it's my actual
size guys it's my actual size we oh I
like when it pumps up and down on my
butt
[ __ ] well it didn't work out look I'm
just gonna say it I don't think old
creaky I don't think we're built for old
creaky because it seems to have a
absolute phobia of getting in a cart so
there's no protection offered it doesn't
work mr. dissonance it's a little better
very cash let's try this one so we can
actually be in it to win it
oh come on creaky let's go let's [ __ ]
go
[ __ ] Wow Oh creaking yeah old creaky
ain't doing so good I [ __ ] love old
creaky but I want to go loco uh mr. each
you've just got bad choices does your
choices are wrong I don't want to call
you an idiot but you're [ __ ] it all
muck I gotta go there's this one
[Laughter]
I didn't know it tooted
oh I'm fine fine apparently what hit me
then oh that way come back baby come
back you can blame it all on me Oh into
the tunnel you've got places to be
markiplier has got places to be he's off
he's off to the races they're all right
well whatever I didn't know it tooted
that's so good oh [ __ ] oh no
well it's to toot into this thing to
toot [ __ ] here we go those giddy
audio girl where did I go okay we're
fine they missed me missed me missed me
missed me
ow well that's boring be excited hey
poke it with a stick
hey do something funny hey come on do
something funny hey you come on do
something funny what are you gonna do
don't stare
[Applause]
look like a [ __ ] toddler where did I
go what happened to me oh boy I'm gonna
get stuck Wow turbine ride that's
probably fine alright let's do this
- dude [ __ ] no no I got a seer I
didn't know why do I have to steer oh
boy here we go come on talk talk by the
fire
[Music]
I think it's cuz I didn't hit the ramp
square on I got it gonna hit the ramp
square that was my first mistake
okay well oh this is my second mistake
nevermind this steering is hard you guys
are like it steers hard hard yeah
oh I just got the SmackDown what the
[ __ ] is that know how that what all
right you know what I'm okay with this
let's toot it up baby
- toot [ __ ] here we go alright
those bad launched but it's alright
yeah oh [ __ ]
I don't think I'm escaping but okay
never get it wait I got try this with a
different vehicle because this seems
like actually something that I could do
aa jogger I like that name
fine
can I get in the tank can I get in it
can I get in the jugger no I guess not
all right let's go for it
come on baby oh we're a little off okay
why are you firing why are you firing
your gun
why are you fire oh no oh no oh it's
going holy [ __ ] oh my god it was whose
gun it was oh well oops I'm fine
that was amazing actually the booty
impressed it was pretty pretty good but
I don't think that's good for me Magnum
is this from the League of Extraordinary
Gentlemen oh hell yeah get an hour
getting it all right wolf
oh no not me not in the face
I I wanted the I wanted the I wanted the
vehicle to hit the mind not my face okay
I'm a something drastic that I never
thought I'd actually say we're gonna
take out some turbo ramps I know I know
what's happened to me I've changed I
know this I know but hear me out if we
are going normal speed maybe we'll hit
it normally what does it take watch just
one in the beginning right full speed
baby
alright now this fun solid fine now we
got a good speed nice ramp okay hey nice
car I don't care let's try the espionage
er I can't fit my head in I can't fit my
head in the car this is gonna go bad
looking for baby cow oh no where did I
go Oh super launch alright but I want my
tutor I want the loco a real turn me up
baby
whoops never mind oops to me out baby
[Music]
and that was the most pitifully pathetic
thing I've ever seen in my goddamn life
get your [ __ ] [ __ ] together the
Squealer
have I seen the Squealer let's go for it
oh hey whoa whoa well it's like a
twelve-year-old on the Internet this is
a squeaker ah all right Jesus Christ
shut up you banshee all right I don't
think there's any way that we can
actually make any significant progress
here so let's get something a bit more
spash smashy smashy i perfect exactly
what I was looking for oh no no no no no
but I can't even make any hi scar wait I
know ski line no I don't know ski line I
don't think I'm supposed to do this one
I think I'm supposed to yeah I'm
supposed to do the streets supposed to
do the streets lie sir I'm furniture
yeah radical ha ha sick oh hell yeah
oh sweet ah beefed it I'm beefed it oh
now what hey rock bottom
like in spongebob well I'm sure it'll be
fine
probably oh well we're going we're
married we're very evenly balanced here
this is this is honestly incredible
gonna be perfectly honest oh [ __ ] well
oh whoa oh my
my head's caught in the tie you guys
remember this one I forgot what it was
all right I think I remember this is
what I always tried to get the ones that
would like lean out the most so that my
head was just sticking forward just a
bus ticket
Oh Oh my ribs are breaking my bones are
breaking but me no hear me not hear me
have no idea me not know where me am we
need a sturdier vehicle now I don't know
if this is actually gonna go well for me
but if I hide in the back I should be
safe right I'm almost positive
huh bulb oh [ __ ] you yeah wait oh that's
so smart we can shoot him before we get
there we'll survive both boom bang II
[ __ ] no hugger you betrayed me jugger
why are you swinging don't swing don't
swing don't swing hey hey we were fine
until the drain decided to insert
himself inside me Oh what the [ __ ]
another trainer
we got double-teamed by two different
drains and then every other car in
existence decided to pay us a visit okay
see you fine totally fine totally fine
the mr. train and mr. mr. [ __ ] train
out of nowhere like the John Cena of
trains you can't see him what derailed
the Train number one okay then we wait
along with a little Lottie [ __ ] da oh
oh I see
Wow no I don't see that's the John Cena
of trains that's like a one-in-a-million
shot that that launched before we even
started this endeavour that one's gone
okay those are gone that's the one I'm
not even on the ground yet oh that's a
direct oh my god I don't remember this I
do not remember that okay I wanted to
say that I remember these things
where my head go my head was there
before my head it wasn't attached to my
body or anything but my head was there
but what else do we have no escape I'm
probably not gonna be that exciting oh
boy alright slow and steady slow slow
and steady oh oh
so normal horrible did we escape I think
we escaped this seems like a bug with
way too many ladies alright we got this
we got this baby we got this baby we got
this baby I got a baby my bones slave my
bones alone I'm getting so many points
from my bones to mine skydive that's
awful that's the worst thing I've ever
seen alright let's let's go for it let's
let's do this here we go
oh oh I have to steer alright steer I
made it
no no come on no you can do it you can
do it just believe oh you could do it
believe it you're back yes yes yes yes
yes yes Wow okay not that great oh don't
throw the gate don't no no no no hit hit
hit no don't go up against the wall hit
something hits something hit shot hit
hit fine then [ __ ] you we're gonna end
on a big blaster Daredevils jump
hmm oh hell yeah oh hell yeah oh hell
yeah give me my boogie boss the far
okay come on go for it why can't the
Boogie buzz fit there we go that's the
good stuff there we go go for it go baby
go hell yeah
oh that economical vehicle really
clocked me out accurate replica of whoa
I see well all right here we go well
well there's been fun thank you
everybody so much for watching you guys
are awesome take care of each other and
as always I'll see you in the next video
[Laughter]
[Music]